let's let's let's talk about media
manipulation and lies because uh you
know i want to say i'm shocked by the
story but i'm not shocked i my i i was i
mean i was kind of shocked okay the new
york post biden white house claims u.s
has zero inflation despite annual rate
remaining at 8.5 joe biden actually said
inflation last month zero percent and i
was like what inflation's at 8.5 it's
insane it's really really bad anyone
who's going you know trying to figure
out their finances right now is is
probably freaking out about this totally
you know what's scary
people are going to believe this and you
know this is
the definition of a recession the
colloquial one is two per two two
consecutive quarters of negative
economic growth bill clinton said it and
you know 2001 or whatever and that viral
video from c from c-span people are
posting and uh the uk considers it that
and all of a sudden they're like no
actually that's not the definition of a
recession so uh we're changing it so
they're saying the technical definition
is actually quite different so now we're
not going to use that this is what
they're doing here
technically joe budden is correct
axios reports
inflation drops to zero in july due to
falling gas prices and what that's not
true it's eight point five percent
i don't think you understand
do you ever play games with little kids
and they make up the rules and then we
start winning they change the roles
right so what they're saying now is
month to month inflation was zero oh my
gosh
right inflation is calculated on a
yearly basis and they decided to change
the way they calculate so they can
report and biden can lie and tell you
there's no inflation and every headline
can say no inflation zero inflation
under biden and they leave out all the
details because they know you're
scrolling you're not actually reading
the article the only the only thing they
need you to get to quote is the
headlines educate me here eight point
five percent does that mean every year
there's gonna be an eight point five
percent from this time last year till to
this month it has increased by eight
point five percent and he's saying last
month it was eight point five percent
this month it's still eight point five
percent zero exactly
[Laughter]
but it went up and then back down so
they're saying it didn't it's so amazing
but then the other the other issue is
it's still 8.5
but food cost is still way up
gas is still way up all of these things
are way up but gas went down a little
bit so so the funny thing is
you also got to understand what it means
for there to be inflation
for there to be no inflation month a
month
if
the the
if gas is skyrocketing
and then it goes up from you know two
dollars to five dollars
and then it drops down to four dollars
and fifty cents they will say inflation
is at zero
even though it's massively up oh my
because it went down just a little bit
just looking at a teeny little bit but
this administration plays with numbers
all the time i mean that
i'm sorry this administration plays with
numbers all the time and they they
really condescend to the american people
because they count on us to be enumerate
or not to know how to read a chart not
to notice i think that's why legacy
media is kind of losing hemorrhaging
viewers and alternative media is is
booming and that's why censorship is so
important because they have to try and
stop that but but i do have to wonder
man does it really matter i think the
democrats maybe you know i'm imagining
they're all like sitting around the
consultants and like the dnc or whatever
and they're like you know we've tried
really hard to convince half this
country why don't we just convince the
stupid people
that's so much easier and you don't need
to spend as much money
so now they're doing things that to us
it's like brazen
inflation is at zero what are you
talking about it's calculated on a
yearly basis how many people right now
are going inflation to zero uh actually
inflation is zero you're wrong here's
axios they said it's zero
and you're like uh
how do you how do you even even
negotiate or argue or compromise with
that i feel like it's just a desperate
move right we're getting so close to
midterm elections that they're like
we're not going to win everybody so
we've just got to get a couple here to
try and try and ease our way into a
victory i said november was going to be
fun
october is going to be fun it's gonna be
crazy like okay so we've been swatted uh
now nine times since january and plus
we've had other security issues you this
group has been swatted yeah nine times
swat
teams come sorry
[Applause]
no no no yeah yeah so so um after the
first like i think two or three times
it was no longer like
multi-jurisdictional armed groups coming
into the house the first time it
happened it was bad like guns dropped
what had you done
we had marjory taylor it's a media
company they build walls around
paramount because people obsess with
media it's too accessible right right so
uh
we we we've we've had all of those
issues and i'm like yeah guys
he thought it was crazy wait till
october
right before isn't it quite traumatic to
be swatted one time let alone multiple
times the first time
you know they actually came guns drawn
and well tim was on air we were we were
on air and the cops like come to the
door and i'm like what is going on and
they're like they're like come out i'm
like i'm coming out what are you doing
in my house you know what i mean good
lord but after that they would come and
do a sweep and then apologize and now
they're harassing you
well not the police the police are
instructed to come for every call i see
so people are threatening you and they
come to protect you people call the
police and then make a fake thing like i
am you know i am a crazy person gotcha
and so the cops were like okay wasn't
there just a twitch streamer who got
shot during this the streamer was
swatted and they got shot during shots
yeah hold on look it up but no there was
a there was a uh two guys who were like
fighting
online on like call of duty and then one
guy said here's my address do something
it was a fake address and when the cut
so the guy swatted the address when the
cops showed up the resident had no idea
what's going on opened his door and
walked out with his gun and the cops
shot and killed
yeah so so anyway i don't wanna i don't
wanna harp on too much of that stuff my
point is just that as we head into
october and november with the midterms
coming up you are going to see the
craziest
balls to the wall shenanigans
all over the country and uh october
surprises if you think there's just
gonna be one no no you're wrong it's
gonna be just everywhere it's like
photos are gonna come out like you're
mentioning weird photos there's like
they're claiming now that alex jones
sent nudes to uh of his wife to roger
stone or something like that like all of
the weirdest things you can ever imagine
they're going to throw everything at the
wall and hope it's time i'm looking at
the deep fix get ready for deep fix i
think that did you see that biden video
where his eyes are open the whole time
and their pure dark black circles looked
like a deep fake i'm not a fake it
looked like a deep fake i couldn't tell
but it didn't what do you mean it didn't
blank he talked about real low voice it
was really weird i think they just gave
him
the world of deep fakes is now be
prepared do not believe what you see at
face value unless it's coming at you
charging you and it's a bear and i i
think they just gave joe biden a bunch
of uppers like i i'm having a hard time
believing he's like listen here
to the point where it's not that i
disbelieve what i see i just don't
believe it and that could be very
dangerous if it's an emergency like if
the boy has cried wolf many times and
now you're here naomi wolfe
hello welcome
do you have faith in the republic
generally in the american republic do
you have faith of its survival oh god
that's such a difficult question are you
you really want the answer
i think that we are at serious risk of
devolving into civil war
hey
i agree you stole tim's life yeah you're
gonna steal tim slogan there's like they
say in the chat they're like every time
tim says civil war drink what steps
would you talk about
oh forgive me if i'm echoing you and i
did not realize no we agree but how much
you guys have in common
to advise a circumvention of that what
would you
what are some gifts you would impart
these are my gifts um
social media and digital platforms uh
you know can be very empowering but
they're also a way to surveil and manage
human communications as we've discussed
there's
we're messaged that the things people do
together are like low tech and second
rate compared to digital tools but in
fact it's incredibly sophisticated a
room full of people talking to each
other or an auditorium full of people
with a speaker talking to a giant group
or a protest or a march with a bunch of
human beings um talking and sharing or a
movement where people are singing and
marching and praying together um so i
would say to everyone the best thing you
can do is
get off your screens and get into rooms
with other humans and have fellowship
with them and feed them and be fed by
them and fall in love with them and you
know disclose your heart to them because
it's only those revolutions that really
are peaceful and survive and it's also a
very sophisticated way to communicate
information because hard to hack the
human brain yet it's hard to hack a room
where people are having a cocktail party
or a potluck or praying together or
singing together um and and we've
forgotten that we can gather like look
at what happened
in this in this country before digital
technology you used to have whistle
stops where people would talk to a
thousand people at once or you know all
the great movements the women's movement
the labor movement the civil rights
movement the abolition movement these
happen in person in real life so
my great blessing to all of you even if
it feels weird if you've been on screens
your whole life is to you know leave the
screens behind for a lot of time and
fall in love with other human beings
we've got a project we're working on
we're going to be opening up a physical
location
where we're going to have gaming uh so
we'll we'll have like a magic gathering
d we'll have card games we'll have board
games we'll have coffee probably maybe
sandwiches or something like that we'll
have skating stuff as well
but the plan is with this space saturday
mornings uh we're going to do saturday
morning cartoons
where the idea is
you don't really have saturday morning
cartoons anymore because everything's
vod on demand digital but when i was
younger we'd wake up on saturday and
watch cartoons so we can have families
come you bring your kids to hang out and
watch good family content that is
approved by the families none of this
weird stuff they're making for kids
there will be like a breakfast buffet
and parents will get to interact with
each other and the idea that i was
having was there's a lot of people that
don't go to church church does provide
some kind of something similar it
provides community so what can we do to
bring more people
hey come hang out saturday morning
something to do with the family we're
gonna have pancakes we're gonna have
waffles eggs sausage bacon some some
vegan and vegetarian options coffee milk
orange juice the kids will watch
cartoons everybody will eat well learn
from each other meet each other and
we'll hang out that's what you got to do
beautiful i love it i love it and
when people actually encounter each
other they realize there's nothing to
fear you know overwhelmingly you know
people will meet who are think they're
across a political divide and they'll
have a conversation and realize like
you're not a weirdo you're not a monster
um our kids are playing together it's i
kind of like it when someone gets heated
and then you still listen to them and
you're still kind of even more bonded
afterwards right because you chose to
listen to them yeah like shut them down
before they got too angry or whatever
gorgeous yeah i love it my my best
learning has come from talking to people
i think i'm going to completely disagree
with i don't know why people are so
scared of it it's so exciting to hear
what someone has to say who totally sees
the world in an oppositional way to
one's own thoughts like how exciting is
that it's you learn so much yeah i used
to chat roulette and i'd come up on
people from china and talk to these
chinese people i don't know if they're
behind the iron curtain
yeah chat roulette you just hit
like roulette and then you randomly
roulette with another sometimes it's
like you know a little bit pornographic
sometimes it's something
great functionality and it was i would
like to hear from them now i want to
know what they're experiencing from the
chinese point of view it's important
that we they won't be able to tell you
the truth if they're based in china but
you should stay in contact with them i
should add to that beautiful scene of
people having pancakes or having potluck
or talking to each other we also need to
know where our food is coming from i
just my husband i just bought a quarter
of a cow from a local
local farmer now we have to freeze her
but i expect
leading up to november
shortages in food
cyber attacks
power grid outages
all kinds of things to destabilize and
scare people and we need to be able to
defend our homes it's another reason to
know your neighbors right
your the internet community that you
build yourself can be great but no one
is going to come help you if let's say a
tree falls on your house or absolutely
you know you need something in the
middle of the night right you need to
know and invest in the people who are
physically around you because ultimately
they control or they influence the
environment you're in and that is more
important than the environment you build
for yourself online because that is
contrived yes i would add to that um
there's so much nonsense about gender
right which i did not intend i i didn't
do it didn't mean it okay sure right i
really didn't
i was never that kind of feminist um but
we we need men you know we need women we
need men we need people of all genders
obviously but
when things fall apart and i thoroughly
expect institutions will fall apart um
you know grids will fall apart there's
going to be chaos leading up to november
and after that's what they want clearly
we need men as well as women but you
think in the next few months we're going
to see this stuff like food shortages
grids we're seeing them i predicted this
i predicted food shortages in in
starting in probably january of this
year and it was a time of great
abundance and we hadn't had empty
shelves and now we have food shortages
you know we you know there people are
going to be cold they're cold in they're
planning on people being cold in europe
because the supply lines the fuel prices
are through the roof thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 p.m and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there
you